hey guys and welcome to nerding out the
show where us GameSpot nerds and you
talk about the things that we like and
today we're talking about Westworld
season 1 episode 9 the well-tempered
clavier
[Music]
let's jump in some viewer theories so we
had one that was absolutely confirmed
knocked out of the park so Jean pissy on
O or picky on O said that board created
Bernard very possibly in the likeness of
Arnold and he also said that in the last
two episodes that Bernard will recall
his history he just nailed it that's
exactly what we saw last night very good
job Jean so let's talk about Bernard
being a recreation of arnold bernhard
old burn arnold let's talk about burn
arnold it's an anagram bernard low and
then arnold what was his last name it's
ended on the door oh it did say yes okay
yeah yeah interesting
well my kind of what i I think here and
I said this last week is that we're
looking for ford's adversary who's gonna
really like make him like whoa i have to
compete to beat this guy because
everybody else he's just laid them to
the side with with no problems right and
we thought maybe it's Arnold that's
gonna be his adversary well apparently
it's not because he just had him commit
suicide so now that we we've met Arnold
it's who's next who is gonna be is it
gonna be Maeve is it gonna be Wyatt is
it gonna be ghost nation and on the
website if you look into ghost nation it
talks about it being a place on the map
that is very difficult to get to but if
you can get there and get in the inner
circle of the ghost nation the reward
the rewards will blow your mind so I
think we're gonna see somebody get into
the inner circle of ghost nation yeah so
that I think that's a key for the finale
exactly and I think we see you know Ford
kind of take a step back and go oh wow
who is this yeah I also just want to
mention that when we think about Bernard
being Arnold we can kind of look back to
those scenes where he's talking to
Dolores in the basement and like oh my
god I've been looking at Arnold half of
the time so I feel like it's um
when Dolores is naked she's talking to
Bernard and when she was clothed she was
talking directly tomorrow and Arnold was
dressed slightly differently I think you
said that his like mustache was slightly
sharper yeah yeah the clean cleaned up
over there
receding hairline yeah yeah I also
wanted to bring up that hey you say
adversary and Arnold was I feel I
believe Arnold was Ford's and Arnold
because of the mix-up between those two
he had Dolores he programmed Dolores to
kill his former partner and she says it
at the end but you don't know if it was
legit or if if you know she was told to
say that but so far yes I said I believe
at this point right now mmm interesting
why does when Dolores says were we
friends and he's like not really no
that's I don't know what that wasn't
really too far into it yeah that was the
previous episode yeah and I think that
kind of there was obviously there was a
close relationship between Dolores and
Arnold right and there was some remnants
of Arnold's code in there she might have
tweaked out and she you know from what I
believe that she massacred a bunch of
people in that town yeah and maybe his
you know Ford's way of dealing with her
was kind of to punish her so it's kind
of a weird relationship right yeah I'll
grab me one side and then it flips on
you and then and then having to you know
punish keep her in a loop a never-ending
loop in check yeah yeah yeah one thing I
want to point out the wheat we kind of
diminished last week as gage was saying
like he thinks that Dolores is Wyatt and
we were like know why it's dude and then
in this episode yeah they just put
different hosts in the place hurry up
maybe not know why himself but inspired
by right yeah well it's totally it's
totally possible right we we totally
knocked his theory down well I did sorry
gage
that's okay let's talk about Maeve
really quick so Maeve was able to
control Bernard why is she that powerful
like this anyone wanting it she can
narrate everything she can control
anyone in the park if anyone is able to
escape I think it's Maeve I don't know
if we're gonna see it next week but I
think she will be able to I
suppose I think she'll get close in the
preview we do see a shot of her and you
know she does like when she's dealing
with the host she's like this is what
they would do to you but I'm not gonna
do it to you so you can tell she's kind
of like taking these house - yeah hey
we're almost ready to get there let's be
conscious together right so having robot
sex with them lighting them on fire you
know just I think that Maeve is part of
Ford's storyline somehow I'm not sure
how directly but I feel like her knowing
this stuff is part of it somehow I'm but
I think that like sentience overall for
the hosts is involved in his storyline
I'm just not sure where the endpoint is
yeah I was going to talk about that but
so I think that you're completely
correct and I'm sure that most of the
internet thinks you're right at this
point I think that the maze is
completely switched the the script is
flipped it was Arnold's to help like
Underground Railroad kind of thing for
hosts and now it's Ford took it over and
now is finding these hosts and he's just
like they're gonna get to the end she's
gonna be like it's gonna be like nah I'm
still I'm still not letting go over the
fort of the host theory just because
I've been pushing it the whole whole
season so I gotta have yeah it's still
possible because Maeve can control
Bernard so Bernard can't control
everybody but maybe he's also just a
robot that's super powered like Maeve
but more so I just think the Ford Maeve
like they are tapped into the matrix and
people are saying voice commands through
narrative but like there's been some
times I think that they've just kind of
been like no yeah and then a robot does
something I'm probably wrong about that
that's my footsteps
actually from chief this week our
producer here buddy was talking about
Maeve's comment saying even at a 14 you
were no match for me and Keith said
Maeve was referring to herself when she
said that in other words even when her
book at perception attribute was 14 she
was still smarter than the tech yep I
was wrong I thought that she was talking
about his perception perception rating
sorry
Internet you're better nerds than me
thanks Keith Thanks alright so moving on
William is the man in black I'm pretty
sure right that's what's gonna happen
next week that's the reveal William was
unhinged at this episode and he just
started shooting and killing everybody
and he's even freaking out Logan looking
like Bob oh dude you really you've got
messed up by this place to the dark side
so that's yeah the picture so the
picture of his fiancee is the picture
that Delores his father freaked out over
and it was more weather at that time so
it totally confirms multiple timelines
does it not yes yes all right so there's
that okay guys so there's one episode
left
what's up predictions for next week the
episode is called the bicameral mind
anyone I'll jump in I have a theory yes
so one of my favorite books is a Kurt
Vonnegut book called the player piano
and it's about AI taking over the world
and destroying everything and it all
starts with this player piano we see a
player piano throughout the entire
season yes we do every time we're in
Fords office we see a piano with a host
playing it so I'm predicting he meets
his match he goes play a little ditty
the guy goes door opens he runs into the
Mazin and that's it nice we're done here
I have not looked up what bicameral mind
means as of yet
just to stay consistent I don't like
sports but if I did I would stay with
one team Ford's gonna be like yellow on
the host and he's just gonna kill
everybody
that's a stupid theory but I have to
stay with it I think I think that we're
going to peep more we're gonna be
revealed that more people are hosts than
we actually thought it may not be it may
not be Ford it hurts to say but I
definitely think we're gonna there's
gonna be at least two more host reveals
in the next episode I think we're going
to see the host that is being created in
the basement where Teresa died
so whoever that room is revealed to be
I've been saying LC bot I'm still
standing by LC bot but it could be
anyone on reddit they were like what if
it's the man in black I'm like whoa what
are you talking about I just come back
to this like final shot of like all the
board members there from Dell O's and
then all of these may even offer crew
like coming up into you know the
underground the the hackers and that's
like part of his like big reveal his
narrative and he just kind of like it
there's some standoff there but he's
controlling the whole thing that there
are which he he has created these
self-aware hosts yeah and and they kind
of break break the barrier between
what's inside the park and the outside
the park got it
and you're liar you do have two words
non-stop yep Maeve is going to make it
out and then it's gonna be revealed that
Ford playing the whole thing and then
the board is all hosts that's what I
should have said earlier you know all
right well you said it we want to know
what your predictions are guys so please
leave those in the comments below and
let us know what you think of this
episode correct us if you need to what
did buddy say weird this episode let us
know and for all things new running out
stick with GameSpot universe
[Music]
you